alors les chéris il était une fois tpm p
et oui 1er avril un vous rappeler de ce
1er avril
alors je vous racontais on avait démarré
sur france 4 c'est vrai que au départ
j'avais fait un grand casting de
chroniqueurs j'avais été voir france
télévisions france télévisions je
faisais fa si la chanter à l'époque et
je savais que fa si la chanter ça
n'allait pas durer très longtemps donc
j'allais voir bruno gaston qui était le
directeur d'épreuve de l'époque et
nicolas pernikoff qu'on a on a la chance
qui travaillent avec nous maintenant
j'espère d'ailleurs qu'il sera avec nous
nicolas pernikoff j'espère qu'ils ont
calé en régie et il faudrait qu'on l'ait
vite pour qu'il nous parle de tout ça je
vous le dis et je leur ai dit voilà je
voudrais faire une émission sur les
médias
voilà donc qui regardent la télé c'est à
dire la télé qui regardent la télé et on
ferait l'émission voilà on donnerait
notre avis comme ça avec des
spécialistes et les comprendrait des
gens une personne de télé 7 jours donc
voilà une personne du figaro une autre
personne
voilà d'un autre journal c'était tv mag
à l'époque c'était isabelle morini bosc
qui travaillait là bas et on sait des
gnons mettrait des journalistes autour
et on ferait chaque semaine donc une
émission sur la télé voilà on dans
laquelle on regarde la télé alors on a
démarré sur france 4 me rappelle la
première audience on avait fait 190
mille téléspectateurs et david jaoui qui
était le directeur d'antenne qu'elle
restait toujours un ami m'avait appelé
ma vie dit c'est pas mal pour une
première voie là mais il faut voir
ensuite on avait joué le dis on avait
baissé 120000 115000 et puis y'a comme
il ya eu un petit à petit un petit voilà
je vous dis un petit buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux sur facebook où les gens
commençaient à dire il ya une émission
où il ya une bande de tarés qui disent
des conneries c'est le jeudi soir sur
france 4
à 22h40 alors c'est vrai que voilà on a
commencé à a pas parlé nous c'est vrai
que moi je m'en rappelle j'avais fait un
dossier
je me rappelle à l'imprimante avec mon
ami yannick voilà kern mes meilleures
amies on avait sorti le dossier on
habite à france 4 avec notre petit
dossier on avait vraiment bien préparé
les choses avec des chroniques des
rubriques qu'on a jamais vu à l'antenne
je vais pas vous mentir
voilà très vite on a dû faire les
chroniques et les rubriques la première
émission après près on apprend on n'a
plus du tout fait ça et c'est vrai que
voilà donc on a commencé et puis ça a
commencé à peser un peu sur les réseaux
sociaux sur facebook un moment on avait
plus de gens qui étaient abonnées à
l'émission sur facebook que de gens qui
nous regardent et donc conseillé
peut-être il se passe un truc
et voilà ça a commencé à monter deux
cent mille trois cent mille jusqu'au
jour où c'est vrai qu'un jour en
deuxième partie de soirée on avait fait
cinq cent quarante mille téléspectateurs
je me rappelle c'est guy lagache
l'invité qui était sur m6 à l'époque
pour capitaux
et d'annoncer dit il se passe quelque
chose on avait fait huit émissions on
avait signé huit émissions sur france 4
et puis derrière france 4 nous a dit on
va peut-être repartir pour une saison
pour voir ce que ça donne et on avait
fait une deuxième année on est dos sur
france 4 et l'émission a commencé à
monter en puissance
voilà et c'est vrai qu'au départ il y
avait vingt trente personnes au public
et il ya des gens qui étaient avec moi
dès le début voile alors là benjamin qui
hélas non gilles non plus mathieu non
plus valérie donc lui n'était pas là
qu'un début parce que le seul
chroniqueurs qui étaient là au début
mais merci d'être là en tout cas les
cherry et merci bagnato taille à ton
fils mon chéri derrière c'est pourquoi
parce que enzo enzo il m'accueille qu'il
a appris que j'allais bosser avec le
midi c'est du tout que j'aime le plus au
monde donc lui voilà il a il a 15 ans
c'est ton fan numéro un il m'a dit mais
non c'est pourquoi je suis fan de lui
mon fils il m'a dit je suis devenu
redevenu ya eu de l'époque du loft et
après il y avait un gros trou noir et
quand il m'a dit déchets known as tu es
bac mon père est là suffire voilà tu
sais que c'est moi je suis fan de lui tu
sais que le clip regardez moi comme il
est beau bah il peut rester avec nous et
moi ça me ferait plaisir qu'il reste là
bien sûr tu restes là est déchiré vous
pouvez réagir bien entendu vous allez
nous donner chacun je pouvais savoir
comment vous avez été recruté dompter
pmp ya plein de gens qui vous demande
pas ce que pour chacun moi je me
rappelle pour chacun c'est une histoire
énorme alors ça lui fait plaisir de voir
valérie qu'est magnifique regarder ma
baloche qu'on n'a pas vue depuis
longtemps ma chérie qui est là tu es
magnifique chéri merci d'être là avec
nous mais c'est un plaisir tu penses pas
agi à aucun moment je pouvais loupé les
dix ans pmp c'est une partie de ma vie
et pour chats bien la professionnelle
vient c'est pour chaque inquiète là
c'est vrai que mine de rien vous avez
tous eu à un recrutement à fait spécial
que vous allez raconter à nos
téléspectateurs et je voulais vous
montrer avant et d'ailleurs vous allez
pouvoir leur poser des questions c'est
pour ça que vous êtes là aussi les
réalisateurs qui travaillent avec nous
certains réalisateurs ya également je
vous dis virginie foucault virginie
foucault la la la fille de jean pierre
qui est aussi productrice qui est une
énorme productrice fabuleuse qui a
commencé à monter le dossier avec moi
sur france 4 la caf des maris des
missions avec moi sur france 4 virginie
virginie qui est là qui est magnifique
regarder les tout bronzé ma chérie
d'amour ça va ma virginie celtique i
alors ce soir je voulais démarre avec
toi ce soir parce que c'est vrai que
c'est toi qui a lancé laventure tpm tu
es avec moi sur france 4 à l'époque et
on va pas se mentir ma chérie on n'y
croyait pas du tout tous les deux en
équipe etc
on n'y croyait pas on a vu tout paraît
guère de soutien pour les producteurs
c'est voir dans 53 et d'ailleurs tu vois
tout paris chaque année à mon avis c'est
vrai qu'apple est ce que tu te rappelles
que je voulais que tu sois chroniqueuse
avons monté mon grand rêve là elle est
en parler jal et en parler ouais j'ai
fait une chronique tu te souviens ou pas
je m'en rappelle très bien et les plus
prolifiques parce que tous les
chroniqueurs qui sont passés par chez
toi bon il ya la photo de famille et
puis après il ya la boîte des
chroniqueurs nous ont été enregistrés à
l'époque c'est à dire vous m'avez
demandé toi nicolas pernikoff de que je
fasse une chronique je suis venu là
faire alors c'est pas mon métier
j'étais vous m'avez coupées au montage
et à lever et par photos choc sur la
photo de famille est là-bas chérie tu
remues que tu résume bien l'esprit tpiy
je souhaitais paix rhdp exige
aujourd'hui c'est c'est grâce à virginie
beaucoup parce qu elle s était un
producteur de l'émission elle a
énormément travaillé avec moi là dessus
donc je voulais absolument démarrer avec
elle ce soit et lui dire que je laime
fort et c'est vrai que virginie et quand
on a démarré l'aventuré
franchement on pensait pas que ça allait
durer 10 ans mine de rien révéler de
l'été avec bertrand war aussi qu'on
embrassait brasse et tout voilà avec
l'équipe aussi à l'époque de france 4
bruno tu en as parlé gagnent renoir yann
renoir exactement fleurance & down
et je voudrais dire eh ben voilà ma
virginie en tout cas
merci d'avoir contribué au succès de
cette émission d'avoir lancé des
missions m format chéri et j'espère te
voir très vite